- ALL RIGHT, FELLAS,
COMING TO THE STAGE NEXT
IS THE BEAUTIFUL GALAXY.
- HEY, BABY.
♪ ♪
OH.
GON' BE FOR YOU.
[chuckles]
YOU CAN KEEP IT.
THERE'S MORE
WHERE THAT CAME FROM TOO.
TRUST ME.
- [whistles]
THERE'S MY GIRL.
OH, DAMN.
I'M STRAIGHT UP TALKIN' 'BOUT
SOME DARRYL DAWKINS RIGHT HERE,
BECAUSE THIS
SOME CHOCOLATE THUNDER.
WHAT, GIRL?
MAKE IT RAIN!
[laughs]
YEAH.
OH, YEAH, GIRL.
- I TRY TO MAKE IT LAST!
[laughs]
- [mutters]
WHAT--
ALL RIGHT, GIRL, MMM.
SHA-PAM! I'MA GET IT
RIGHT IN THE BOOTY RIGHT THERE.
UH, AND BOOTY-SWAM!
THAT'S WHAT YOU CALL
A BOOTY INVESTMENT.
[laughs]
SHA-BLAM!
- BUT YOU REALLY DON'T NEED
TO GIVE 'EM THAT MUCH.
I DON'T THINK
THEY'RE EXPECTING ALL THAT.
- WHOO!
- IT'S KIND OF LIKE
FEEDING A SQUIRREL, YOU KNOW?
I MEAN, THEY WILL
COME BACK TO YOU, SO--
- OH, OH, OH, MY GOSH.
SOME OF THIS IS GETTING LOST.
LET'S GET IT RIGHT
WHERE IT NEEDS TO BE.
RIGHT IN THERE, BABY. OH, YEAH.
- KEEP IT CLASSY.
- HA HA HA!
- OH, [bleep], SOMEBODY
BETTER GET A UMBRELLA,
'CAUSE I CAN'T STOP
MAKING IT RAIN.
IT'S LIKE NOAH'S FLOOD
UP IN HERE.
WHOO, TWO BY TWO, BABY.
TWO BY TWO! HA HA!
BABY, YOU DON'T KNOW
THAT I'M THE GENERAL,
'CAUSE IT'S STORMIN' NORMAN.
THAT'S WHAT THEY BE CALLING ME.
[Velcro slowly tearing]
AHH.
- DAMN.
ANYWAY, LIKE I SAID,
WHEN YOU FINISH TRAINING,
WE'LL GET SCOTTY MUSSO
UP IN HERE.
THAT [bleep]
CAN TRAIN A BOXER.
[laughs]
OOH, LORD HAVE MERCY.
YOU DON'T KNOW NOTHING
ABOUT THIS. [laughs]
- MAKE IT RAIN!
- AAH!
- WHAT THE--
- ARE YOU AN IDIOT?
LEON,
GET THIS GUY OUTTA HERE.
- ALL RIGHT, NOBODY MOVE!
THERE HE IS.
- THERE WHO IS?
- YOU, ON YOUR FEET!
- WHAT?
- ON YOUR FEET.
- WHAT I DO?
- YOU'RE UNDER ARREST
FOR PHOTOCOPYING MONEY.
- OH, GODDAMN IT!
YOU KNOW HOW LONG IT TOOK ME
TO CUT ALL THAT OUT?
I GOT CARPAL TUNNEL SYNDROME
UP IN THIS BITCH,
CALLUSES ON THE INSIDE
OF MY THUMBS.
- THAT'S DEFINITELY REAL,
THOUGH.